qui sera miss réac 2022 alors
ressemblent vous n'êtes vous êtes avec
eric zemmour valérie pécresse qui est au
milieu magnifique marine le pen
magnifique également et vous magnifique
aussi comme ça ça vous va très bien eric
zemmour donc voilà qui est un niveau qui
sera miss real 2022 en tout cas ça fait
rire les gens n'osent plus qu est ce que
ça vous dérange ce genre de une ou pas
du tout non d'abord j'adore charlie
hebdo vous êtes charité c'est la liberté
et on a besoin de cette liberté sur la
caricature c'est valérie qu'est la plus
belle et moi
c'est assez rare que j'ai un maillot
deux-pièces voilà c'est la première
tranche des cours ça vous tue m'arrive
genre de trucs ouais bien sûr quand on
dit que vous êtes un peu réac voilà
comme la basse qui lisent voilà ils
disent que c'est vrai qu'il ya quatre
candidats voilà avec des défenses très à
droite voilà même si c'est la droite
républicaine pour valérie pécresse et
vous qu'est ce que vous avez envie de
répondre à charlie hebdo c'est font leur
métier font ils font leurs leur métier
c'est la caricature c'est normal c'est
comme le canard j'étais aussi à la une
du qatar du canard canard la tuer et
c'est vrai que bon aujourd'hui on le
voit il ya énormément de candidats de
droite on a l'impression que la gauche
n'existe plus on l'a vu anne hidalgo
étaient au shit et f donc ils vont
certainement faire un record à la baisse
son audience
je l étais dans lequel je suis arrivé à
l'heure et ma rêverie ou pas vous l'avez
regardé nom est maintenant arrivée très
serrée alors anne hidalgo qui a dit
qu'elle souhaitait une primaire avec un
goal com vous elle vous copie donc à
voudrait moyens qu'elle allait se
retirer france alors oui mais la définir
c'est bon
[Applaudissements]